It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢忙碌时，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. You know the stereotypes. Men are from Mars, women are from Venus. Love is a battlefield. And in the search for romance, there are natural winners and losers. Young, attractive women, and powerful, wealthy men will always hold the upper hand. These ideas permeate popular culture, and their proponents say that evolution itself made us this way. And who can argue with science? But psychologists who study close relationships have found that this view of human partnering doesn't accurately reflect what actually makes people fall in love or stay committed to their partners. Today we're going to talk about the science of love and bonding.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。你知道那些刻板印象吧。男人来自火星，女人来自金星。爱情是战场。在寻找浪漫的过程中，天生就有赢家和输家。年轻迷人的女性和强大富有的男性总是占据上风。这些观点渗透在流行文化中，其支持者声称进化本身造就了我们现在的样子。谁又能反驳科学呢？但研究亲密关系的心理学家发现，这种人类伴侣关系的观点并不能准确反映人们坠入爱河或保持忠诚的真实原因。今天，我们将讨论爱与联结的科学。
Are there real gender differences in what men and women are looking for in relationships, or is that just a myth? What makes two people compatible, and is it possible to predict which couples will make it? How have dating apps change the landscape of love and relationships? And if you're on the apps, how can you use them better? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Paul Eastwick, a professor of psychology at the University of California
男女在择偶时是否存在真正的性别差异，还是那仅仅是个神话？是什么让两个人变得契合，预测哪些情侣能长久是否可能？约会软件如何改变了爱情和关系的格局？如果你正在使用这些软件，又该如何更好地利用它们？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是 Kim Mills。我今天的嘉宾是加州大学心理学教授 Paul Eastwick。
Davis, where he leads the attraction and relationships research laboratory. His research looks at how people form romantic relationships and the psychological mechanisms that help romantic partners stay committed to. to each other. Last year, we spoke with him and his colleague, Dr. Eli Finkel, about their podcast Love Factually, which analyzes romantic comedies through the lens of relationship science. Today, we're happy to have him back on speaking of psychology to talk about his own research on relationships and about his new book, Bonded by Evolution, The New Science of Love and Connection. Dr. Eastwick, thank you for joining me today.
戴维斯分校，他在那里领导吸引力与关系研究实验室。他的研究着眼于人们如何建立浪漫关系，以及帮助伴侣保持忠诚的心理机制。去年，我们曾与他和他的同事 Eli Finkel 博士讨论过他们的播客《Love Factually》，该播客通过关系科学的视角分析浪漫喜剧。今天，我们很高兴他能回到《心理学谈话》，谈谈他自己关于关系的研究，以及他的新书《Bonded by Evolution, The New Science of Love and Connection》（进化联结：爱与连接的新科学）。Eastwick 博士，感谢您今天参加节目。
Thank you so much for having me back, Kim. You open your book by describing what you call the Evo script. So start by telling us what is Evo script, why is it problematic for how we think about relationships? Yeah, I think what I refer to as the Evo script. It refers to a set of assumptions about the way human mating works that supposedly reflect the pressures that existed in our deep ancestral past. And I think these ideas grew out of a reasonable scientific literature, but things have advanced a little bit in the last few decades.
非常感谢邀请我回来，Kim。你在书中开篇描述了你所谓的“进化剧本”（Evo script）。那么，先告诉我们什么是“进化剧本”，为什么它对我们思考关系的方式是有问题的？是的，我所指的“进化剧本”是指关于人类交配方式的一系列假设，这些假设据称反映了我们遥远祖先过去所面临的压力。我认为这些想法源于合理的科学文献，但过去几十年来，情况已经有了一些进展。
And we know now that these pillars of the science aren't quite what they used to be. So the Evo script, as I describe it, has three components to it. One is the idea that mate value is central to the way that people approach relationships, you know, to put it colloquially, there are tens and sixes and twos, and, you know, you better hope you're a 10 and it's better to be a 6 than a 2. And the second pillar is the idea that men and women are really different in what they want out of romantic relationships. They pursue different things. They care about different things, et cetera. And the third pillar is this idea that people can strategically pursue short-term or long-term relationships and that people are good at different things.
我们现在知道，这些科学支柱并不完全是它们过去的样子。正如我所描述的，进化剧本有三个组成部分。一是认为“伴侣价值”是人们处理关系的核心，通俗地说，就是有 10 分、6 分和 2 分之分，你最好希望自己是个 10 分，而且 6 分总比 2 分好。第二个支柱是认为男女在浪漫关系中的需求截然不同。他们追求不同的东西，关心不同的事物等等。第三个支柱是认为人们可以策略性地追求短期或长期关系，而且人们在不同方面各有所长。
Some people excel at flings and some people are really the kinds of people you'd want to settle down with. To me, the contemporary research on attraction in close relationships takes issue with all three of these ideas. Well, let's talk about the differences, supposed differences in what men and women are looking for in relationships. If they're not different, what are they? Why do we think they're different? Yeah. So, I mean, this was really where I got started studying attraction. I was interested in these gender differences. And we had known for a long time that when you ask men and women about the attributes they want in a partner, for some traits, you get reliable differences. So, for example, if you ask men and women, how much do you care about an attribute like physical attractiveness? Men will say they care about it more than women.
有些人擅长露水情缘，有些人则是你真正想安定下来的那种人。对我来说，关于吸引力和亲密关系的当代研究对这三个观点都提出了质疑。那么，让我们谈谈男女在关系中追求目标所谓的差异。如果它们并不不同，那它们是什么？为什么我们认为它们不同？是的，这确实是我开始研究吸引力的起点。我对这些性别差异很感兴趣。我们早就知道，当你询问男女对伴侣属性的要求时，对于某些特质，你会得到可靠的差异。例如，如果你问男女，你有多在意身体吸引力这样的属性？男性会说他们比女性更在意。
And when you ask men and women, how much do you care about an attribute like earning potential or ambition? Women will say they care about it more than men. These are very reliable differences in what men and women say they want in a partner. But it occurred to us, I mean, nearly 20 years ago now, but it occurred to us that, But what happens when people meet potential partners in real life? If the evolutionary perspective is correct that these gender differences reflect what really matters to people, what really drives their liking for potential partners, then we should see, for example, at a speed dating event, that you see gender differences in the appeal of these traits as they are revealed by real potential partners that you're meeting. So to give a concrete example, let's say that you're a woman and you're going speed dating and you're meeting a bunch of guys. And let's just to make it easy, say that six of these guys are pretty ambitious and six of them are not.
当你问男女，你有多在意赚钱能力或野心这样的属性？女性会说她们比男性更在意。这些是男女在择偶要求上非常可靠的差异。但我们意识到，虽然这已经是近 20 年前的事了，但我们想到：当人们在现实生活中遇到潜在伴侣时会发生什么？如果进化视角是正确的，即这些性别差异反映了人们真正看重的东西，真正驱动他们对潜在伴侣产生好感的东西，那么我们应该看到，例如在速配活动中，当遇到真实的潜在伴侣时，这些特质的吸引力应该存在性别差异。举个具体的例子，假设你是一位女性，你去参加速配，遇到了一群男士。为了简单起见，假设其中 6 位很有野心，另外 6 位没有。
What I want to know as a relationships researcher is, okay, so do you find the ambitious guys more appealing than the unambitious guys? and if so, by how much. And we can put a number on that. We might call it like a 10% bump in how women in general feel about the ambitious guys relative to the unambitious guys. But the kicker here was that when you do this same thing with the genders flipped, it's the same story. That is the ambitious women, they're liked about 10% more than the non-ambitious women.
作为一名关系研究员，我想知道的是：你是否觉得有野心的男士比没野心的更有吸引力？如果是，程度是多少？我们可以给它一个数字。我们可能称之为女性对有野心男士的好感度比没野心的提升了 10%。但关键在于，当你把性别互换再做一次实验时，结果是一样的。也就是说，有野心的女性比没野心的女性受欢迎程度也高出约 10%。
And we saw that time and time again with the various attributes we looked at. Yeah, attractiveness does provide a bump for people. It's useful early on to find somebody to be physically attractive, but it didn't matter whether men or women were making those judgments. And this was our first clue that there might be a big difference between what people say when they're circling traits on paper versus what actually appeals to them when they're meeting people face to face. What about same-sex couples? I mean, how do they evaluate these same kinds of attributes? Yeah, it's a great question. And the amount of data, you know, speed dating data on same gender attractions, I mean, it's shockingly and embarrassingly small. When we did conduct an event for gay men and, you know, I went back and looked at the appeal of these various attributes. And honestly, like the appeal of earning potential among the gay men, it looks like what you saw with the various mixed gender pairing. and same thing with the appeal of attractiveness, too.
我们在观察各种属性时一次又一次地看到了这一点。是的，吸引力确实能为人们加分。在早期阶段，找到一个身体上有吸引力的人很有用，但这与是男性还是女性在做判断无关。这是我们的第一个线索，表明人们在纸上勾选特质时所说的，与他们在面对面接触时真正被什么所吸引之间，可能存在巨大差异。那么同性伴侣呢？他们如何评估这些同样的属性？这是一个很好的问题。关于同性吸引力的速配数据，说实话，少得令人震惊和尴尬。当我们为男同性恋者举办活动时，我回头看了看这些各种属性的吸引力。老实说，赚钱能力在男同性恋者中的吸引力，看起来和你在各种异性配对中看到的一样。吸引力的吸引力也是如此。
It looked like what you saw with the mixed gender pairings. These are small samples. Like, we need much bigger samples to know for sure. I mean, this is really a case where the amount of data we have on mixed gender couples unfortunately dwarfs what we have for same gender relationships. But my hunch is that stories will be similar for these kinds of abstract attributes that often afford some amount of motivated reasoning, right? I mean, if you like somebody, if you think they're funny,
它看起来和你在异性配对中看到的一样。这些样本很小。我们需要更大的样本才能确定。这确实是一个关于异性恋伴侣的数据量不幸远超同性关系数据量的案例。但我的直觉是，对于这些通常提供某种动机推理空间的抽象属性，情况会是相似的。我的意思是，如果你喜欢某人，如果你觉得他们很有趣，
you'll have a tendency to think they're more attractive and vice versa. So I think for these kinds of attributes, we're likely to see more similarities than differences. Well, let's get back to the book because one of the main points that you make is that compatibility is the secret sauce that makes relationships work. And successful relationships are not necessarily, about funding the best partner but about funding, the best partner for you. So let's talk about that. What's compatibility? What makes it so important? Yeah, so here's the way I like to break down
你往往会觉得他们更有吸引力，反之亦然。所以我认为对于这类属性，我们可能会看到更多的相似之处，而不是差异。让我们回到书本，因为你提出的主要观点之一是“契合度”（compatibility）是让关系奏效的秘诀。成功的关系不一定在于找到最好的伴侣，而在于找到最适合你的伴侣。让我们谈谈这个。什么是契合度？是什么让它如此重要？是的，这就是我喜欢为人们拆解
compatibility for people. This comes from the work of the great Dave Kenny and his social relations model. That's the official name for this way of thinking about judgments, but I'll try to break it down very simply here. If I say that I find somebody attractive, what Dave Kenny would say is that's not one judgment, it's three. And the three components of that judgment are, I might be a selective person or not. You know, I might think everybody's hot, or maybe I think nobody's hot.
契合度的方式。这来自伟大的 Dave Kenny 及其社会关系模型的研究。这是对这种判断思维方式的正式称呼，但我会尝试在这里简单地拆解它。如果我说我发现某人很有吸引力，Dave Kenny 会说这不是一个判断，而是三个。该判断的三个组成部分是：我可能是一个挑剔的人，也可能不是。你知道，我可能觉得每个人都很火辣，或者也许我觉得没人火辣。
That's a selectivity component. A second one that's going to end up mattering here is the consensus or the popularity component. Maybe this person that I'm making a judgment about, maybe everybody thinks that she's super hot. Okay, that's popularity. And then the third component is what we call compatibility. And that is the part of my attraction judgment that is really about how I feel about this person specifically that isn't about my selectivity and isn't about her popularity.
这是一个选择性成分。第二个最终会产生影响的是共识或受欢迎程度成分。也许我正在判断的这个人，也许每个人都觉得她超级火辣。好吧，那是受欢迎程度。第三个成分就是我们所说的契合度。这是我吸引力判断中真正关于我如何看待这个特定的人的部分，它与我的选择性无关，也与她的受欢迎程度无关。
And what you can do with the right kind of data is you can break it down and see, okay, here we got all these people making these attraction judgments. We've got a bunch of people at a party or at a speed dating event or what have you making judgments about how much they like each other. And what you regularly see is that the biggest component of those three, you might think it's popularity. It actually turns out its compatibility. So that's the biggest thing happening, right? Yeah, there is agreement about who's popular at first, but even more important than that is the spread around that agreement about whether somebody is an eight or a 10. right, that somebody might be an eight. That's the average judgment that that person gets,
你可以利用正确的数据将其拆解，看看：好吧，这里有所有人在做这些吸引力判断。我们在聚会或速配活动中有一群人在判断他们有多喜欢对方。你经常看到的是，这三个成分中最大的一个是——你可能认为是受欢迎程度——但实际上证明是契合度。所以这是发生的最重要的事情，对吧？是的，起初对于谁受欢迎是有共识的，但比这更重要的是围绕这种共识的差异，即某人是 8 分还是 10 分。对吧，某人可能是 8 分。那是那个人得到的平均评价，
but that means that some people think that they're a 10 and some people think that they're a six. So that spread around somebody's popularity. That's where the compatibility component lies, and it's very important for understanding how relationships take shape. Do you have any sense of how long it takes to figure out whether you are compatible? Yeah. I mean, this is the trick, right? Because If we could figure it out for moment one, and if we knew that, okay, I find you especially appealing and that's going to stick, boy, would that be handy. But there are a couple of interesting wrinkles here. The first is that the power of that compatibility component, it actually
但这意味着有些人认为他们是 10 分，有些人认为他们是 6 分。所以围绕某人受欢迎程度的这种差异，就是契合度成分所在的地方，它对于理解关系如何形成非常重要。你是否知道需要多长时间才能弄清楚你们是否契合？是的。我的意思是，这就是诀窍，对吧？因为如果我们能在第一刻就弄清楚，如果我们知道：好吧，我发现你特别有吸引力，而且这种感觉会持续下去，那该多方便啊。但这里有几个有趣的转折。首先是契合度成分的力量，它实际上
grows over time as people get to know each other. And what I mean by that is that over time, people's opinions will start to diverge even more from that consensual average. So if, if you originally, you know, oh, everybody agrees you're like an eight. Well, that means with time, now we got people who think you're a four and, you know, people who think you're a five, right? We've got now spread all over the place. Now, some people like you more than when they first met you and other people like you less. So that's what I mean by there's more compatibility there. But the challenge here is that compatibility, especially early on, can be unstable. In other, other words, my impression of you is going to differ a lot more between the first time I meet you
随着人们相互了解而增长。我的意思是，随着时间的推移，人们的观点会开始比那个共识平均值更加分歧。所以，如果你最初，你知道，哦，每个人都同意你是 8 分。好吧，这意味着随着时间的推移，现在我们有人认为你是 4 分，有人认为你是 5 分，对吧？我们现在到处都是差异。现在，有些人比刚见面时更喜欢你，而另一些人则更不喜欢你。这就是我所说的那里有更多的契合度。但这里的挑战在于，契合度，尤其是在早期，可能是不稳定的。换句话说，我对你的印象在第一次见到你
and the second time I meet you, then it will between like, I don't know, the thousands time I meet you and the 99th time I meet you, right? Those impressions aren't going to differ nearly as much. So I always recommend to people like zero in on compatibility, right? The people that you like especially highly, but also acknowledge that how you feel about somebody is probably going to change over the course of the first few interactions. And that's okay. That's part of, you know, the process of figuring out, like, is there compatibility here and is it likely to be stable and something that we can build off of? Now, I know that you are not a matchmaker, but you do a lot of research involving speed dating and you see how people react to each other. Is there any way to predict
和第二次见到你之间会有很大的不同，这比在，我不知道，第一千次见到你和第 99 次见到你之间要大得多，对吧？那些印象不会有那么大的差异。所以我总是建议人们：专注于契合度，对吧？那些你特别喜欢的人，但也要承认，你对某人的感觉可能会在最初的几次互动中发生变化。这没关系。这是弄清楚“这里是否有契合度，它是否可能稳定，以及我们是否可以以此为基础”的过程的一部分。现在，我知道你不是媒人，但你做了很多涉及速配的研究，你看到了人们如何相互反应。有没有办法预测
people's compatibility. I mean, can you look at their backgrounds and personality traits and similarities and use that information to make a prediction? Yeah, if only it were that easy. And, you know, for a long time, these ideas have been bouncing around, you know, 10, 15 years ago, many of the online dating companies were claiming that they could do this, you know, take questionnaires about various people, check out your personality, your values, your attitudes, and bring the sensible matches together. As time has gone on, it has become more and more clear that this is extremely difficult and perhaps even impossible.
人们的契合度？我的意思是，你能看看他们的背景、人格特质和相似之处，并利用这些信息做出预测吗？是的，如果那么容易就好了。而且，你知道，很长一段时间以来，这些想法一直在流传，10 到 15 年前，许多在线约会公司声称他们可以做到这一点，你知道，通过关于各种人的问卷调查，检查你的个性、价值观、态度，并将合理的匹配对象聚集在一起。随着时间的推移，越来越清楚的是，这极其困难，甚至可能是不可能的。
I'll describe one of the studies by my colleague, Dr. Samantha Joel. I think she's done some of the best work in this space. What she did is she ran machine learning studies where she took all sorts of data about people, before they had ever met face to face, all that kind of information about their personality and their attitudes and their values and their preferences. And what machine learning can do is it can say, all right, if there are good matches in here, I'll find them.
我将描述我同事 Samantha Joel 博士的一项研究。我认为她在这一领域做了一些最好的工作。她所做的是运行机器学习研究，她获取了关于人们的各种数据，在他们面对面见面之前，所有关于他们的个性、态度、价值观和偏好的信息。机器学习可以做的是，它可以说：好吧，如果这里有好的匹配，我会找到它们。
You know, you researcher, I don't need your ideas about who matches with whom. I'm just going to find the signal in the noise here. And it runs thousands and thousands of iterations. And what she found was that she could predict exactly 0% of the compatibility component at speed dating events. So in other words, there was no signal about who was going to be compatible with whom based on the information that people reported about themselves ahead of time. It had to emerge organically from the interactions between people. once they had met face to face. This was a big moment for me
你，研究员，我不需要你关于谁与谁匹配的想法。我只是要在这些噪音中找到信号。它运行了成千上万次迭代。她发现，她能预测速配活动中 0% 的契合度成分。换句话说，基于人们提前报告的关于自己的信息，没有任何关于谁会与谁契合的信号。它必须在人们面对面见面后的互动中自然产生。这对我是个重大时刻，
because it really shifted my understanding of, you know, shifted my focus from trying to figure out like, okay, if the compatible couples, if they're not going to be found over here, well, maybe they're found over here. Like surely there's a rhythm and a math to what makes people click or not. And I now think it's much more about
因为它确实改变了我的理解，你知道，将我的注意力从试图弄清楚“好吧，如果契合的情侣在这里找不到，嗯，也许他们在那里找到”转移了。就像肯定有一种节奏和数学来决定是什么让人们一拍即合或不合。我现在认为这更多是关于
what two people grow and build together rather than something preordained in their individual differences before they meet. I'm wondering, I'm going to make an assumption here that you've looked at the work of the Gottman's who look at couples. And they talk about how they can predict with something like 80% accuracy. I mean, they've been on the podcast, whether couples are going to last. I mean, is that, do you find that as well? Yeah, I mean, the way that I think about these.
两个人共同成长和建立的东西，而不是在他们见面之前就预先注定在他们个人差异中的东西。我想知道，我在这里做一个假设，你已经看过 Gottman 夫妇的研究，他们观察情侣。他们谈论他们如何能以大约 80% 的准确率预测——我的意思是，他们上过播客——情侣是否会持久。我的意思是，你也有同样的发现吗？是的，我的意思是，我思考这些
ideas is that once you have a relationship in front of you, again, I'm trying to predict what's going on from before the beginning of time, before two people even meet in the first place. But once a couple has a relationship and it's often running, you can absolutely look at the dynamics of that couple and say, this is trouble. These are not good conflict tactics. Or you can say like, hey, these people know how to love and support each other. This seems pretty well. You could absolutely do that. I would take issue with the term prediction to describe that. I would say you're kind of describing what's happening now and because what's happening now tends to predict what's happening tomorrow and what's happening tomorrow, that it's not a
想法的方式是，一旦你面前有一段关系，同样，我是在试图预测在时间开始之前，在两个人甚至见面之前正在发生什么。但一旦一对情侣有了关系并且进展顺利，你绝对可以观察那对情侣的动态并说：这很麻烦。这些不是好的冲突策略。或者你可以说：嘿，这些人知道如何去爱和支持彼此。这看起来相当不错。你绝对可以做到。我会对用“预测”这个词来描述它提出异议。我会说你是在描述现在正在发生的事情，而且因为现在正在发生的事情往往能预测明天会发生什么，以及明天会发生什么，所以它不是一个
prediction exercise in the same way it would be to try to take people who are kind of all at the same level, like before a relationship was formed, and then predict ultimately who's going to end up with whom. So it's like a different way of talking about the process of prediction, but you can absolutely look at the dynamics of couples and say, this one looks good and this one looks like trouble. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Eastwick about what science says about love at first sight. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199.
像试图在关系形成之前，将处于同一水平的人们放在一起，然后最终预测谁会和谁在一起那样的预测练习。所以这是一种谈论预测过程的不同方式，但你绝对可以观察情侣的动态并说：这一对看起来不错，这一对看起来很麻烦。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与 Eastwick 博士讨论科学对“一见钟情”的看法。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。
And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price-in-valed May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough.
整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，有例外情况。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？足够了。
Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises.
足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。
It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Let me ask you this one, is there really such a thing as love at first sight? I mean, I know we all want to believe that that's so, you know, but maybe that's just something that happens in the movies, which I know is another interest of yours. Yes. In fact, it happens in the movies shockingly frequently. But this is a tricky question to answer because a lot of people have the experience of falling for somebody right away. But I think that it's also common that people have the experience of having somebody grow on them over time.
你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了住宿。让我问你这个，真的有“一见钟情”这回事吗？我的意思是，我知道我们都想相信那是真的，你知道，但也许那只是电影里发生的事情，我知道这也是你的另一个兴趣。是的。事实上，它在电影中发生的频率高得惊人。但这是一个很难回答的问题，因为很多人都有立刻爱上某人的经历。但我认为，人们随着时间的推移对某人产生好感也是很常见的。
we've tried to come at this issue by getting people to chart the course of their relationships over a long period of time. We try to actually get them to go back to the beginning, back to when they first met the person. And we can see how did you feel about this person over the length of time that the relationship lasted? And so we can look at that first moment that people met and use that as a gauge of where this thing is going, right? Is it true that, oh, when people initially meet and fall for each other,
我们试图通过让人们记录他们关系在很长一段时间内的过程来解决这个问题。我们试图让他们真正回到开始，回到他们第一次见到那个人的时候。我们可以看到，在关系持续的时间里，你是如何看待这个人的？所以我们可以观察人们见面的那一刻，并以此作为衡量这件事走向的标尺，对吧？是真的吗，哦，当人们最初见面并爱上对方时，
that that's a good sign or maybe it's a bad sign? The reality is you see a huge spread at the beginning for how people feel. On average, most relationships that will go somewhere, the average one, I don't know, people feel kind of me when they first meet. But that's the average. Underneath that average, yet there's like 20% of people who feel very positively about that person the first time they met them. And indeed, they went on to have a relationship with this person. This is about like 30 to 40% of people who are at the bottom of the scale who think when I first met you, I thought nothing of you whatsoever. But you grew on me over time. So both trajectories are possible. And importantly, ultimately, it kind of doesn't matter. Like,
那是一个好迹象，还是一个坏迹象？现实情况是，你在开始时会看到人们的感觉有巨大的差异。平均而言，大多数会有所发展的关系，平均来说，我不知道，人们第一次见面时感觉一般。但那是平均水平。在平均水平之下，确实有大约 20% 的人第一次见到那个人时感觉非常好。而且确实，他们后来与这个人建立了关系。大约有 30% 到 40% 的人处于量表的底部，他们认为当我第一次见到你时，我根本没把你当回事。但你随着时间的推移让我产生了感情。所以两种轨迹都是可能的。而且重要的是，最终，这其实并不重要。就像，
the relationships of the people who initially felt a lightning bolt and the relationships of the people where it grew from basically nothing over time, they all kind of got to the same high place eventually. So, you know, it's exciting when you catch lightning in a bottle like that it's exciting when you feel that love at first sight get you. But ultimately, it's not that key. And I just always want to remind people very commonly. People's impressions start from near rock bottom and grow to be something meaningful eventually. Well, let's say that you're no longer just dating, that now you're in a committed relationship. So what does your research say about how to keep those relationship bonds strong and to keep the spark from going out?
那些最初感到“闪电击中”的人的关系，以及那些随着时间推移从基本为零发展起来的人的关系，最终都达到了同样的高度。所以，你知道，当你像那样捕捉到“瓶中闪电”时，这很令人兴奋；当你感受到那种一见钟情时，这很令人兴奋。但最终，那并不是关键。我总是想提醒人们，非常普遍的是，人们的印象从接近谷底开始，最终成长为有意义的东西。好吧，假设你不再只是约会，现在你处于一段忠诚的关系中。那么你的研究对于如何保持这种关系纽带的牢固以及如何防止火花熄灭有什么建议？
Yeah, and this is tricky because, look, the average relationship does get harder over time. people do become less satisfied over time on average that there are many couples who don't experience that decline over time. And unfortunately, there are many couples who do. I like to point to a couple key features, which is certainly consistent with a lot of the approaches of researchers in decades past, like the Gottman's, et cetera. I talk a lot about motivated reasoning. Motivated reasoning is a very important tool that people have for maintaining their relationships. Motivated reasoning is honestly important for doing anything hard. It's sometimes very useful to have rose-colored glasses, maybe about how you're doing and how things are going, because it inspires you to want to push further and to maybe generate
是的，这很棘手，因为，看，平均而言，关系确实会随着时间的推移变得更难。人们平均而言确实会随着时间的推移变得不那么满意，有很多情侣并没有经历那种随时间的衰退。但不幸的是，有很多情侣确实经历了。我喜欢指出几个关键特征，这当然与过去几十年研究人员（如 Gottman 夫妇等）的许多方法是一致的。我谈论了很多关于“动机推理”（motivated reasoning）。动机推理是人们维持关系的一个非常重要的工具。老实说，动机推理对于做任何困难的事情都很重要。有时戴着玫瑰色眼镜看待你正在做的事情以及事情的进展是非常有用的，因为它激励你想要更进一步，并可能产生
something of a self-fulfilling prophecy. In the context of a close relationship, what that often means is acknowledging your partner's faults, but sort of putting them aside in the little box that says, you know, hey, everybody has faults like this. If I were with somebody else, they would have the same faults or even worse faults. Also, the things that my partner has going for her, those are things that not everybody has. These are little tricks that people have that help them to maintain their relationships when times are tough. And finally, maybe the most important motivated reasoning trick of all, and I think this is relevant to some of the evolutionary narratives that we've gotten, is the motivation to what's called derogate alternative partners. In other words,
某种自我实现的预言。在亲密关系的背景下，这通常意味着承认伴侣的缺点，但把它们放在写着“嘿，每个人都有这样的缺点”的小盒子里。如果我和别人在一起，他们也会有同样的缺点，甚至更糟的缺点。此外，我的伴侣所拥有的优点，是并非每个人都拥有的。这些是人们在困难时期维持关系的小技巧。最后，也许是最重要的动机推理技巧，我认为这与我们得到的一些进化叙事有关，那就是所谓的“贬低替代伴侣”（derogate alternative partners）的动机。换句话说，
when alternative partners become apparent, people have a really funny way of seeing those alternative partners as being less desirable than they actually are. That's a useful protective mechanism for a relationship. And this can also help to explain why ultimately, you know, if people match and say mate value or something like that, why that doesn't ultimately matter that much, why a relationship between a quote unquote eight and a quote unquote five can be perfectly fine because if other eights are now approaching this eight and trying to form a relationship with them, the eight is using their derogation of alternative powers and seeing those potential suitors as not all that desirable. So this is an important tool in the relationship toolkit
当替代伴侣变得明显时，人们有一种非常有趣的方式，将那些替代伴侣看得比实际更不理想。这对关系来说是一种有用的保护机制。这也助于解释为什么最终，你知道，如果人们在伴侣价值等方面匹配，为什么这最终并不重要，为什么一个所谓的“8 分”和“5 分”之间的关系可以完全没问题，因为如果其他 8 分现在正在接近这个 8 分并试图与他们建立关系，这个 8 分正在使用他们贬低替代者的能力，并将那些潜在的追求者视为并不那么令人向往。所以这是关系工具箱中的一个重要工具，
that most people deploy most of the time. Let's talk for a bit about dating apps. How have they change the way that people form relationships and are they starting to lose their luster or are people still using them as much as they ever did? Yeah, I mean, I hear tales that people are gravitating away from the apps. I don't know how good the data are exactly, but, you know, it certainly seems that the worm has turned on the dating app experience. But of course, people are still using them and relationships are still forming that way. I think the apps have some value for people who have social networks that feel broken and stale. They can be useful ways of finding partners where you weren't going to be able to meet them otherwise. But I also think
大多数人大部分时间都在使用它。让我们谈谈约会软件。它们如何改变了人们建立关系的方式？它们开始失去光彩了吗，还是人们仍然像以前一样频繁地使用它们？是的，我的意思是，我听说人们正在远离这些应用程序。我不知道数据到底有多准确，但，你知道，看起来约会软件的体验确实已经发生了转变。但当然，人们仍然在使用它们，关系仍然以这种方式形成。我认为对于那些社交网络感觉破碎和陈旧的人来说，这些应用程序有一些价值。它们可以成为寻找伴侣的有用方式，否则你将无法遇到他们。但我同时也认为
the apps reinforce a mode of dating that is really depressing for. a lot of people. The apps very much cater to the idea that there are tens and twos, right? Because in an app market, the winners are going to win big time. There's not a lot of room for compatibility when people are swiping. And what that means is that the people who are attractive get tons of swipes and the people who are in the lower part of the distribution don't get as many. That kind of unequal market, it's kind of a bummer. And actually, honestly, like, doesn't work that great for anybody because if you're very desirable, you're sort of inundated with requests. And if you're not that desirable, you kind of want to throw the thing
这些应用程序强化了一种对很多人来说非常令人沮丧的约会模式。这些应用程序非常迎合“有 10 分和 2 分”的想法，对吧？因为在应用程序市场中，赢家会赢得巨大。当人们滑动时，没有多少空间留给契合度。这意味着有吸引力的人会得到大量的滑动，而处于分布较低部分的人则得不到那么多。那种不平等的市场，有点令人沮丧。而且老实说，对任何人来说效果都不太好，因为如果你非常令人向往，你会被请求淹没。如果你没那么令人向往，你有点想把这东西
in the sea. So, you know, that's, I think, one of the main problems with the apps. It also, I think, because of the inundation effect, it exaggerates and magnifies. It exaggerates and magnifies. gender differences. You know, one example of this has to do with some of the attributes we were talking about earlier. So, yeah, when you're just swiping, it's very tempting to stay with the surface level attributes that you can assess easily, okay? And women will tend to swipe right on the tall guys or the guys who have good incomes. Are these going to be the guys that will ultimately make them happy face to face? Who knows? It's a total dart throw. But people do all this filtering with who they're looking for and, you know, ultimately I would argue it's a
扔进海里。所以，你知道，我认为这是这些应用程序的主要问题之一。我认为，由于淹没效应，它夸大并放大了性别差异。你知道，这方面的一个例子与我们之前谈论的一些属性有关。所以，是的，当你只是滑动时，很容易停留在你可以轻松评估的表面属性上，好吧？女性往往会向右滑动高个子或收入高的男性。这些会是最终让他们面对面感到快乐的男性吗？谁知道呢？这完全是掷飞镖。但人们在寻找谁时做了所有的过滤，而且，你知道，最终我会说这在最好的情况下是
time wasteer at best and demoralizing at worst. Is there a way to use them effectively? I think, like, there are a few ideas that I rather like. Look, if you're going to use the apps, try to not get so much in your head about what your type is. But at the same time, to the extent that you can give somebody more than just a 20-minute, you know, resume exchange over coffee, that's also a wise thing to be able to do. So it's like sample more broadly than you typically do, but also take the time to try to actually get to know somebody even better. I mean, I wish this were easier to do. boy, I wish we could meet people without so much of the romantic pretense and the romantic pressure. Like what happened to meeting people and like, I don't think this person's for me,
浪费时间，在最坏的情况下是令人沮丧的。有没有办法有效地使用它们？我认为，有几个想法我相当喜欢。看，如果你要使用这些应用程序，尽量不要在你的“类型”上想太多。但与此同时，在你能给某人超过 20 分钟的、你知道，喝咖啡时的简历交换的程度上，这也是明智的做法。所以就像比你通常做的采样更广泛，但也花时间去尝试真正更好地了解某人。我的意思是，我希望这更容易做到。天哪，我希望我们能在没有那么多浪漫伪装和浪漫压力的情况下遇到人。就像“遇到人”发生了什么，比如，我不认为这个人适合我，
but I'd love to introduce them to this friend of mine. That's the social connective, you know, these social muscles that I worry have atrophied that we aren't doing as much of. Let me introduce you to these other people. This is a thing that exists. I wish it were more popular. Sometimes it's called a used date party. But the idea is like you go to this party and you bring a date,
但我很乐意把他们介绍给我的一位朋友。这就是社交连接，你知道，我担心这些社交肌肉已经萎缩了，我们做得不够。让我把你介绍给其他人。这是一个存在的事情。我希望它更受欢迎。有时它被称为“旧约会派对”（used date party）。但想法是，你去参加这个派对，你带一个约会对象，
but the date is somebody you met through an app and the two of you didn't click. So there your date and you're going there to this party to meet other people who didn't click with their dates. I love ideas like this. We're encouraging face-to-face interaction. You like sort of have this like weird way. man, but I don't know, it sounds kind of fun to me. So I like ideas like this. If you're going to use the apps, geez, let's find more creative ways of turning it into real social interaction out in the world. In your book, you talk about how ideas from evolutionary psychology are not only harming
但那个约会对象是你通过应用程序认识的人，你们俩没看对眼。所以那是你的约会对象，你去那个派对是为了见其他没和他们的约会对象看对眼的人。我喜欢这样的想法。我们正在鼓励面对面的互动。你有点像有这种奇怪的方式。天哪，但我不知道，这对我来说听起来很有趣。所以我喜欢这样的想法。如果你要使用这些应用程序，天哪，让我们找到更多创造性的方法，把它变成现实世界中真正的社交互动。在你的书中，你谈到了进化心理学的观点不仅在损害
people's understanding of relationships. They're leading to misogyny and other social harms. what goes wrong when people start to internalize these ideas? Yeah, I mean, this has been one of the eye-opening things for me of the last decade. You know, I'm a practicing psychologist. I conduct research. I, you know, debate things in the journals with evolutionary psychologists, and all of that has been great. But it has been disturbing to see how that science has been warped and twisted online
人们对关系的理解。它们正在导致厌女症和其他社会危害。当人们开始内化这些想法时，哪里出了问题？是的，我的意思是，这是过去十年中让我大开眼界的事情之一。你知道，我是一名执业心理学家。我进行研究。我，你知道，在期刊上与进化心理学家辩论，所有这些都很棒。但看到这些科学在网上被扭曲和歪曲，用于这些相当邪恶的目的，是令人不安的
for these pretty nefarious ends. And that was actually part of the realization for why I wrote this book in the first place, because I realized that, whoa, whoa, all these folks online, they're like drawing from this 1990s version of the science that they don't know how much things have changed over the last few decades. The tricky thing when you're talking about evolutionary processes, something is evolved, something is biological, something is genetic, is that the everyday person hears the message, oh, this thing will be harder to change. And sometimes that gets twisted into some pretty regressive stuff.
而这实际上是我写这本书的部分原因，因为我意识到，哇，哇，网上所有这些人，他们就像是从 1990 年代的科学版本中汲取信息，他们不知道过去几十年来事情发生了多大的变化。当你谈论进化过程时，某事是进化的，某事是生物学的，某事是遗传的，棘手的事情是普通人听到的信息是“哦，这东西将更难改变”。有时这被扭曲成一些相当倒退的东西。
And I think that's what's happened. So it's not that there was something wrong with the science per se. I mean, I do think the science was leading us to the wrong conclusions. I'm not blaming the science for what happened. But I do think now is the time for us to get a little bit more response. about this because we scientists also sometimes accidentally convey these messages like oh well you know men's desire for sexual variety it exists everywhere it's survived all attempts to eradicate it i guess there's not much we can do about it it must be evolved like scientists absolutely say that
我认为这就是发生的事情。所以并不是科学本身有什么问题。我的意思是，我确实认为科学在引导我们得出错误的结论。我并不责怪科学导致了发生的事情。但我确实认为现在是我们对此更加负责的时候了，因为我们科学家有时也会不小心传达这些信息，比如“哦，好吧，你知道，男性对性多样性的渴望，它无处不在，它在所有试图根除它的尝试中幸存下来，我想我们对此无能为力。它一定是进化的。”科学家绝对会那样说，
and people will absolutely take that and run with it even when even when like By the way, there's no evidence. I mean, please show me the study where we tried to change men's desire for sexual variety. There are none. We've not actually tried to do that. So don't tell me it can't be changed. This is not something we've attempted. But when you tell people that something is evolved, they just hear that it's hard to change.
人们绝对会接受这一点并随之奔跑，即使当——即使当——顺便说一句，没有证据。我的意思是，请给我看那个我们试图改变男性对性多样性渴望的研究。一个都没有。我们实际上并没有尝试那样做。所以不要告诉我它不能改变。这不是我们尝试过的事情。但当你告诉人们某事是进化的，他们只是听到它很难改变。
We need to be better at really communicating when is something hard to change and when it's easy to change and what can we do about it, ultimately? Given how much gender stereotypes have changed through the years, I mean, maybe not as much as some of us would like, but how has that had impacted dating practices in the current time where we are? Yeah, it's interesting. The overtime research is fascinating. I think some of the best work comes from like sociologists. They tend to have really good data for how things have changed over time. And sometimes, you know, the real people out there in the world, they're the ones changing and the scientists are a little slow to catch up. And the commentator certainly. But here's one example. It's a lot of hand-wringing today about the plight of men and boys and their educational prospects. And I totally get this.
我们需要更好地真正沟通什么是很难改变的，什么是容易改变的，以及最终我们能对此做些什么？鉴于性别刻板印象多年来发生了多大的变化，我的意思是，也许不像我们中的一些人希望的那样多，但这如何影响了我们当前时代的约会实践？是的，这很有趣。随时间的研究非常迷人。我认为一些最好的工作来自社会学家。他们往往有关于事情如何随时间变化的非常好的数据。有时，你知道，现实世界中的真实人们，他们才是正在改变的人，而科学家们有点反应迟钝。评论员当然也是。但这里有一个例子。今天有很多关于男性和男孩的困境及其教育前景的焦虑。我完全理解这一点。
Like, this is indeed a challenge. And it's going to be a tough challenge. It's going to be a tough problem to solve. But accompanying that, you get this insinuation that somehow men's poor education prospect is linked to the rise of singles or something. Like, women are kind of opting out of these guys, and men are intimidated by these women who have better educations than damn. There's no evidence for this.
这确实是一个挑战，而且将是一个艰巨的挑战，是一个很难解决的问题。但随之而来的是一种暗示，即男性的教育前景不佳与单身人士的增加或其他什么原因有关。好像女性在选择远离这些男性，而男性又被那些受教育程度比自己高的女性所震慑。但这并没有证据支持。
The sociologists know this, and this has been a change that we have seen over the past several decades. For example, it used to be true that marriages were a little rockier when the woman earned more than the man. This changed in the 90s. Beginning in the 1990s, marriages that formed then, the woman earns more than the man, the man earns more than the woman, doesn't matter. Okay, so that gender difference has gone away. I fear commentators have not caught up to this. Same thing when we look at educational differences today. Woman's more educated than the man.
社会学家们对此很了解，这是我们过去几十年来看到的一种变化。例如，过去确实存在一种情况，即当女性收入高于男性时，婚姻会稍微不稳定一些。这种情况在90年代发生了变化。从20世纪90年代开始，在那之后形成的婚姻中，无论是女性收入高于男性，还是男性收入高于女性，都没有关系。所以，这种性别差异已经消失了。我担心评论家们还没有跟上这一变化。当我们审视当今的教育差异时，情况也是如此。女性的受教育程度高于男性。
Yeah, that's happening more these days. I mean, it's got to be. They're earning more degrees. Are these relationships in trouble? No, they're fine. So, like, the panic that sometimes people express reflects like these older ideas that are pretty dated. and sometimes, you know, the science advances and the people advance without us necessarily realizing it. So a lot of our listeners I know are raising kids, particularly teens, and I'm wondering how we can guide young people to a healthier understanding of relationships when they're surrounded by these toxic ideas.
是的，这种情况在今天越来越普遍。我的意思是，这必然会发生。她们获得了更多的学位。这些关系有问题吗？不，它们很好。所以，人们有时表现出的恐慌反映了那些相当过时的旧观念。有时，科学在进步，人们也在进步，而我们未必能意识到这一点。我知道我们的许多听众都在抚养孩子，尤其是青少年，我想知道当他们被这些有毒的观念包围时，我们该如何引导年轻人建立更健康的恋爱观。
Yeah. I mean, I think the scariest thing for me is it's just the level of pessimism about relationships. in general that I think varies from like, who needs it to, to, you know, almost like if you're heterosexual, it's like the other gender is this, you know, creature from another world that you can never begin to understand, you know, much less form a close relationship with. I worry about this a lot. I worry about people who aren't able to form mixed gender friendships.
是的。我的意思是，我认为最让我害怕的是人们对人际关系普遍存在的悲观情绪。这种情绪从“谁需要它”到“如果你是异性恋，异性就像是来自另一个世界的生物，你永远无法理解，更不用说建立亲密关系了”。我非常担心这一点。我担心那些无法建立异性友谊的人。
I mean, that's a clear example that you see in the science that men and women who are heterosexual, if they have more friends of the other gender, they are more likely to form a relationship, usually because that's how they're meeting friends of friends or friends of friends of friends. So that kind of, you know, those kinds of interactions with people who are a little different than you tend to be helpful in a practical way and also in a way that expands your mind and expands your perspectives. So if young people today aren't getting practice, spending time with people who aren't like them or people who aren't their gender, I do, that's something that certainly concerns me. As for the online discourse, I mean, you know, other than the mantra that,
我的意思是，你在科学研究中看到的例子很清楚，异性恋男女如果拥有更多异性朋友，他们就更有可能建立恋爱关系，通常是因为他们是通过朋友的朋友，或者朋友的朋友的朋友认识的。所以，那种与你稍有不同的人进行互动，在实际层面上是有帮助的，而且也能开阔你的思维和视野。因此，如果今天的年轻人没有机会与那些与自己不同的人或非自己性别的人相处，这确实让我感到担忧。至于网络上的言论，我的意思是，除了那个口号，即
that like online is not real life. And you really have to get out there and meet and interact with people. I mean, anything that parents can do to encourage their kids to spend real time interacting with folks. I mean, it's so weird to be in the position as a parent these days of being like, oh my gosh, will you please like go hang out with people and get into trouble?
网络不是现实生活。你真的必须走出去，去见人并与人互动。我的意思是，作为父母，现在能做的任何鼓励孩子花时间与人进行真实互动的事情都是好的。作为父母，现在处于这种境地真的很奇怪，就像是“天哪，求求你去和别人混在一起，去惹点麻烦吧？”
Yeah. Like, oh my gosh, like stay out late, break curfew for the love of God. But I do think that that's where my advice, tends to go these days. So what are you studying now? What's next?
是的，就像“天哪，去外面玩晚点回来，看在上帝的份上打破宵禁吧”。但我确实认为这就是我现在的建议倾向。那么你现在在研究什么？接下来要做什么？
What are the questions that you still want to answer? Yeah, I mean, one of the things I'm really interested in these days is around this, you know, how do people digest messages that have a biological or evolved flavor to them? What are the assumptions they make about findings like that? So we would tell people in these studies, things like, oh, people commit infidelity. because it's biological and they evolved to do so because they're evolutionary advantages. Or we tell them that it's due to a motivational drive something psychological in them. So, you know, more of a non-explanation explanation.
你还有哪些问题想要回答？是的，我的意思是，我最近非常感兴趣的一件事是，人们是如何消化那些带有生物学或进化色彩的信息的？他们对这类发现做了什么样的假设？所以我们在这些研究中告诉人们，比如，人们之所以会不忠，是因为这是生物学上的，他们进化出了这种行为，因为这有进化优势。或者我们告诉他们，这是由于某种动机驱动，是他们内在的心理因素。所以，这更像是一种非解释性的解释。
And you see that people make these assumptions about automaticity, harder to control when you tell them that something is biological. So we want to figure out what are the kinds of phenomena, people are more likely to make those, this thing is hard to change judgments. And what is the kind of information that we could use? Oh, can we give people a biological explanation, but then also explain why this doesn't have implications for how hard something is to change or for how important it would be to design and intervention and see what that does too? Because I really am becoming more and more concerned about how these findings are digested by people. I don't want anybody to stop using
你会发现，当告诉人们某件事是生物学上的时，他们会做出关于自动性的假设，认为它更难控制。所以我们想弄清楚，对于哪些现象，人们更容易做出“这件事很难改变”的判断。我们可以利用什么样的信息？哦，我们能否给人们一个生物学解释，但同时也解释为什么这并不意味着某件事很难改变，或者为什么设计干预措施并不重要，看看这会产生什么影响？因为我确实越来越担心人们是如何消化这些发现的。我不希望任何人停止使用
evolutionary perspectives. I love evolutionary perspectives. I have a different one than mainstream evolutionary psychology, but evolutionary perspectives are really, really important, but we got to understand how the average person digest them, and we got to be ready with a scientific answer when those interpretations go awry. All right. Well, Dr. Easter, I want to thank you. you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Thank you. Thank you again so much for having me back. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you like what you've heard, leave a review, follow us. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us
进化视角。我喜欢进化视角。我与主流进化心理学的观点不同，但进化视角确实非常非常重要，但我们必须了解普通人是如何消化它们的，当这些解释出现偏差时，我们必须准备好科学的答案。好了，Easter博士，我要感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的很有趣。谢谢。再次感谢你邀请我回来。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请留下评论并关注我们。如果你对未来的剧集有意见或想法，可以发邮件给我们
at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced. by Lee Wienerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state.
地址是 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wienerman 制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价商品。当你下载 Ralph's 应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，你还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省 1 美元。在 Ralph's，你每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省下一大笔钱。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年。储蓄可能因州而异。
Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
燃油限制适用。详情请见网站。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。